hi everybody welcome to punch-drunk
sportswear sports podcast is any I'll
deal with the litter okay yep you got
make a good point
none of these mics are on headphones
right oh we don't have speakers oh the
mics are on the mics are on they just
suck on mine doesn't
she put these on you dumb [ __ ] idiot
put it on you can hear it and welcome to
punch drunk sports everybody thank you
for the audience how are you guys you
guys are rad what's up everybody make
some noise [ __ ] let's give it
up for the one chick who gets it
everybody one lady she's 1,000 there's
another white guys that's what we've
done the math a fact wait guys and the
three black listeners that's what's
that's when I have a question for the
lady two of them wait there's two oh I
see her too I know I know the answer to
her Peterson his arm is around her who
are what what boyfriend possessed both
of you to be here and are you how
confused are both of you do you guys
actually listen the punch-drunk you just
supportive okay I'll take that what
about you in the back do you also listen
no she sometimes sometimes is a way of
saying no I understand that no problem
she's Brazilian oh oh go on you ever go
on your soundcloud and listen to where
people listen like you'll see like
[ __ ] North Korea and [ __ ] so weird
you know what that is those are VPNs
what's that mean China that can't like
download in China caused illegal so you
use a service that makes you go through
like Switzerland or losing Bob ley guys
let's give it up for the all things
comedy crew for put together
[Applause]
why are you doing your like executive oh
yeah executor of this good point I'm
boom aren't you on the like the board of
the way
what's the score the Dodgers game right
now shut up four one four one five one
five one who other than one Dodgers up
five one nope wait with the same license
oh okay
now ari what happened enjoy our pain
dude why we all enjoy each other's pain
now ari what happened when we were at
the pool today it seemed Tripoli's that
what happened we were at the pool today
you seem to have gotten ahold of my
phone and tweeted some disparaging
things about me and not disparaging I
don't I saw what you tweeted about how
much you love Black Hawk and how you
love to be cooked uh and I apparently
like to watch black guys [ __ ] me in the
ass while I stare at myself in the
mirror yeah that'd be weird if you
[ __ ] didn't like watching yourself
getting [ __ ] an ass but you were
getting [ __ ] in the ass that is yeah
that's called prison yeah that's true
that's true they need better mirror
systems in prison really now I everybody
listen to our show knows Ari throughout
this next 90 minutes and Dan is no Neil
would be joining us in 45 minutes
but Ari gets snap hops thrown in them at
our whim for the entire show so I'm
gonna give this back bet that he lost
does anyone in the world series comes
when in the world every time I was wrong
what a welcher so I'm not a well sure
every time he did [ __ ] welcher shut up
you shut up no Sam at any time you want
to throw him in Ari or at his body or
his face and I'm going for the eyes I'm
not gonna lie I'm going for the eyes i
when we made this bet I still wearing
glasses I think we should make this an
official function podcast and re take
your pants off at due time
you know I'm a lady man so don't so
today we did some interesting stuff for
hi you look like you're rolling your own
cigarettes right now I feel like I am I
feel like if I smoke these it would be
really bad um so today we did uh we we
had our 40-yard oh yeah we did our 40s
so before we tell you what happened I
think guesses as to let's first of all
can I give you a hint that happened to
me when we were running the 40-yard dash
and if you see my knee it's way worse
see but went all out for sure
whoo let's hear some guesses about like
who came in first second and third
thoughts anybody anybody Sam was last
that's the part that's the first the
first guest
Sam was last anybody else about who was
first or second Thank You Man I had to
keep in mind Tebow has been chased by
police dogs twice in his life now watch
twice I could have used them today I'm
not gonna lie it does have crack speed
yeah a guy that's never smoked crack
which is an underwriter you just made
anybody has crack unless anybody has
crack we'll show the results in a minute
I guess does anybody want to make bag of
bets on who's who's coming for a second
and third in the audience let's make a
bet about dad yes he does yes he does
blind you're not gonna go wide yeah
you're only gonna go blind if I get in
your eyes you're so close is an eyebrow
you don't need to see to do podcast
millionaire are we supposed to read this
what is it our sponsors we are recording
live from the ATC pop-up podcast studio
in downtown Phoenix at the all things
Comedy Festival presented by Bud Light
cityscape and Tito's handmade vodka yes
by the way Sam carefully pronounced
every single word correctly in the host
shot
when you started reading that I'm like
there's no words no way and he's one of
the top six people that shouldn't be
reading this killed it thank you hello
real quick there's a dead guy outside
anyone see the dead guy yeah there's a
dead dude right outside just laying
there like [ __ ] beef jerky and nobody
seems to care is gonna be awesome
Oh after you [ __ ] Bonnie I'm so excited
to torch you Audion twitter so Dan is
only on Twitter and apparently Instagram
you guys got pretty good stretchin Brown
the stretching everything's cool
everybody be cool
so Denis Denis will be joining us live
45 deg SP will be here probably die
skull probably dies we find out the
chance because the websites almost where
are we honestly on this podcast two
weeks away or two weeks away from now
that we have a chance let's take a
caller from let's take a caller does
anybody have any suggestions or anything
you'd like to talk about while we
actually have the opportunity on why we
can't get calls because Johnny [ __ ]
sucks black dicks yeah okay well notice
I have nothing to do with the phone
calls what we were able to take them
before you start sucking black dick yeah
so that is true the power the black dick
where is Aaron I noticed Aaron has been
hiding he's not even oh the areas ladies
and gentlemen Aaron let's give a big
round of applause for Aaron wake up
Aaron he takes a beating but not that
being that his wife's a [ __ ] tastes
like Ari didn't they say they couldn't
get us callers because you show your
butthole too much they tried saying that
that's there nothing to do with the
callers though why is it I don't
understand why I said the an issue
because you show your your Jew hole too
much it's an accused if anyone knows
about excuses just tell them why you
[ __ ] being way around we're it by the
way does anyone wear immense immense
medium that's a men's medium yeah this
is I were
and shrunk oh we got a min we gotta do
you don't look like a medium bro you
look like a god he just wants a Sam
Tripoli's fat shirt
you ain't no medium you know he looks uh
this is the bass I throw one snap power
Darrin any leaves you wear tomorrow okay
are you a fan of the show oh yeah [ __ ]
you yeah you're not getting it
you seemed like you were a media yeah
yeah dude he talked about meth head
he seems like if he keeps doing coke
he's gonna be a small and three month it
looks like it looks like a phoenix meth
yeah they should I heard they're
renaming the the what's like all the
Diamondbacks to the meth I don't even
want to see you see me grab one cuz then
you start to get defensive
yeah so we ran the we went to University
of Phoenix University of Phoenix which I
thought was just an online school yeah
yeah I was like by the way finish
college Christina's college yeah it's
kind of like going to like a UH
some kind of like a call center in India
you like you don't know there's an
actual place yeah it's just something
you hear about all the time that shows
up everywhere like if you have a degree
from University of Phoenix online you
also have a minor in googling things
yeah there were taken Phoenix online
is that like like sports teams there
yeah we saw volleyball team or our
soccer team so oh no that's not that's
the university institution I'm just
saying it's a different College yet -
JUCO right what the [ __ ] that supposed
to mean why's it gotta be Jewish dude
know it means a bunch of Jews try to
play Jewish sports
what are Jewish sports by the way the
dreidel Olympics balancing checkbooks
worry worry worry yeah yeah yeah yeah
pulling up perfectly every time a lot of
judgment oh really
yeah that's actually not Jewish thing at
me yeah how about this one genetic
diseases from so much inbreeding
we just specific diseases only affect us
also this you have a major in that not
yet not yet not yet not yet but I swear
to god I'm gonna blind you before this
show's over well by the time you're done
you're gonna look like you were in that
scene of Django Unchained body I promise
you every studio in we break everything
all right why are your pants on can we
get our E's balls no no we've seen his
balls a lot let's get this going the
ladies wanna see it look at him they're
smiling with anticipation
I've seen your wrecked u-haul come on
let it out and what do you see the
episode where are you showed his butt
hold I had vise grips on it
oh you guys work with the show guys
welcome to gay poetry night thank you
for coming you guys gay you guys gay you
wanna do some poetry you guys got black
dicks right okay Carrie get a Mike Mike
stretch over there hey let's see these
take your pants off fellas welcome to
the podcast
what are you guys doing if you're
selling candy I'm gonna [ __ ] kill ya
oh no if anybody wants to buy some
five-dollar peanut M&Ms okay
hey let's let him come up and tell a
joke tell us a joke over come on up and
tell a joke fella no joke over here
[Applause]
Sammy took the log ah sit down join us
what's your name
davontea Dante talking in this mic Oh
Josh how many people here think they
spelled two vantes name anybody anybody
I think it has two V's in it I know
there's an exclamation point somewhere
outside the box second starts with the T
like a painful situation right here so
where jokes are killing okay y'all want
to hear plea dirty clean erases jokes
don't don't
jung-hwan dirty clean eraser dude it's
will take a racist look at your crowd
they're all pedophiles good luck the
last thing we want how do you get a
Jewish girl's number yeah this is good
oh let us all guess Sam I feel like I
feel like the answer is gonna be very
very nasty I mean okay I know it is you
[ __ ] do well in business and then you
let the word go out in the community and
eventually you say you're single and
talk to the matchmakers of the town and
then they mentioned someone's looking
and then you say could I have your
number and then she gives it to you you
actually have to live for sleeve
gotta live for sleeve oh dude this kid's
got a black belt with his black dick my
gosh was rape all right so what's the
difference it's when a Jewish person in
a pizza I love this dude you won't be on
the chauffeured I would like a pizza to
be in the room I would like a pizza in
the room that's my guess okay okay the
pizza does the screaming oven oh dude
this is good stuff okay
I think so ins the next Kevin Hart when
you own a costume when you're like how
would you like a racist joke I didn't
know it like I wasn't irate I mean I'm
in on ball there's a black guy and
there's a white guy standing on the top
of the same branch yeah see yes I aren't
it great so both of the guys that's not
the word but go on
alright okay maybe okay dude don't seem
to pop it I've seen the pop it hit me
now it's his back it just bounced off
his back okay so black guy white guy on
top of the same branch yeah they both
jump off at the same time which one hits
the ground first
the white guy cuz the black guy was
lynched Oh everybody quiet on that one
this is a free play you just made white
girls uncomfortable which means you
probably get laid after this okay well
thank you candy you got what candy you
got yeah what are you running a scam
[ __ ] with a maple candy oh my
god jokes
I got audio you got no candy just walked
in a Cell joke I got jokes yes my jaw
fell at all
let's hear a dirty joke you said he had
a racist joke all right what's the
difference between a woman in a washing
machine what's the difference you can
dump a load in it and it won't follow
you around is great what great how old
are you I'm a sophomore in high school
holy sophomore high school sweet 16 yeah
hey you want to open for Ari Shaffir
exactly exactly
here's $1 for your jokes drop out of
college give it up for random kids going
up good luck dude good luck I feel like
we just saw the new biggie smalls of
stand-up comedy if like biggie smalls
and Hitler had a baby anything aside
take care man I like how his buddy
doesn't get any of the food this is not
quick
hey his I'll be sure son also was left
with him look this is why we need more
callers okay back to the back to the
running it was fierce it was fun
Johnny you want to break down the times
first first run talking raised
controversy there's no controversy oh
yeah that's pretty much say I'm just
going he came in last no Sam convinced
me there's dog talk about go on and
there will be film to be reviewed Ari's
biggest fan is like all-time Ari yeah so
this guy really shows up I think how
exactly think he's a crisis actor okay
who just happened to show up Sam doesn't
believe in Las Vegas or the Newtown
shootings I don't believe in any of that
[ __ ] they happened but not the way they
say anyways you think the catch you
think the kid shot the shooter what in
which one you talk to Newtown you think
that shot in Vegas you think they shot
into the hotel room the whole thing is
just [ __ ] weird dude everyone
with that no okay all right oh by the
way that's a different pocket okay so
this kid just [ __ ] shows up I know
it's like hey I saw weed and I just
thought I'd show up randomly we did said
whoever wants to come down you should
come down yeah that's convenient so one
guy shows up off of an re-tweet yeah off
of an are you a Mexican kid shows up to
watch the amazing racist who probably
tried to get his dad deported in a video
no shows up and [ __ ] decides the time
gotcha gotcha conspiracy conspiracy all
you want so this random kid shows up
he's like and he's like Ari's like hey
why don't you time us conveniently yeah
sure yeah I said somebody's okay okay
they got this guy loving you yeah
that'll move right on the bald spot
around you have our first times yes I do
oh thank you that's my bad that's what I
just got read off first times by the way
just so you know I was taking short
strides and I was held my breath the
entire way I wasn't thinking oh my
defense I won in the first times and I
smoked a cigarette and I feel like
that's my Popeye spinach and I should
have kept smoking so go on first times
you're okay so your son who's using our
his fat walks in with 19 candy bars he
didn't get jokes and those guys they got
the right actual candy hey how come he
didn't come in ah do the the rod yeah
Burt said he was gonna come but he were
gonna come you said you're gonna come
and run hey you have Reese's Pieces in
your mouth we can't hear you about nine
of them Burt last night said he wanted
to come and do a 40s against us and then
I was like yeah sure we'll wait till
you're done with radio and then uh and
then uh ladies and gentlemen yeah and
then he was Michelle leaving at 11:00 he
goes for Chrysler one of the best all
about silver Burt looks hungover
look at how much you look like you went
trick-or-treating in Beverly Hills can I
have a king nineteen yeah by the way
just
sidebar the sponsors sponsored by
Reese's peanut butter cups the kind with
Reese's Pieces inside it the King kind
with Reese's Pieces inside if you had
those yet I don't like them
what do you mean uh
don't elaborate I don't like I like them
I love oh I don't like em it's too much
busy
yeah that's busy it's like too much
surprises in your mouth I love I love a
Reese's Peanut Butter Cup but you don't
like but do you like Reese's Pieces
I love Reese's Pieces and you don't like
them combined I do not like them
combined
that's like let's make Ari pay for that
every now and then they don't [ __ ] it up
World Series first I took the field so
let's talk about let's talk about the
race because I predicted a triple he's
put too much of a hurt on his body and
he's not good enough shape to beat
anyone what about team team you've got
that quick twitch working muscle that's
not what I heard you sad
you said what yeah no problem
and when I smoke cigarette smoke
cigarettes for the first race and I did
much better and I should have smoked
throughout the entire you've got Tweaker
muscles like you got those nervous
Tweaker muscles yeah and I've been
running my whole life not physically but
just emotionally but I thought I've seen
Ari swim it's uncomfortable I gotta beat
you in swimming and I are uses his body
parts like it's not his first day like
it's his first day using them like he
just got brand new body parts and
they're like alright try him out he's
like oh that was a good one right behind
the ear I'll go ringing yeah that's what
the cops do to you [ __ ] oh that's like
in cop land where they shot that [ __ ]
sucker right behind Sylvester Stallone
space yeah that's all it's called you
just learned all the lessons you just
learned I can't wait to get that Juno's
I might be in a bad spot I think you're
safe
I think you're safe so how much did I
already beat you guys by well we're
discussing that right now we're never
reveal the answer yet but we were
reversible through the first our first
numbers okay first on warmed up my nibs
that I ate for school [ __ ] yeah go
first one already comes out with a six
nine five six nine five remember that
number six nine five guts important
that's [ __ ] important here might held
my breath the whole time short straw pop
go Jason comes out with a six eight
seven after that okay round of applause
thank you everybody
and then Sam ran a six nine seven so I
type in essentially zero two seconds
good time are you lost so I came in last
I've forgotten re it sounded like the
last number all right so it came in last
so who won the first one you yeah boys
dead ahead of time we're gonna do best
time takes it okay so that's the first
run everybody by the way already knows
what happened go to the second one
now at any point did anyone look at this
kids ah timer I did both runs not the
last one not to bury all the runs about
the very last one okay the very last one
was what yeah me okay okay ahaha
go on just remember our he's first
number and that was its first run seven
seconds basically so Sam runs first the
next time and run bruh a six four nine
Sam is now in first place yeah Sam is
now in first place
come on video then Jason comes out six
for six
he's now in first place yeah okay so
we're right next to each other yeah but
that's now on that run another tie
another time can I say no
give me my defense on that run I was
trying to be you know romantic and make
it sexy and I try to do like where you
run across the tape
no tape and you lean in yeah and then
everything below my waist came out all
the heavy night started doing
somersaults and I was about kid on my
face
I was about to skid on my face and like
I'm like oh man I got to do a podcast
and a stand-up show tonight like I can't
just be looking like [ __ ] you know I
continue Turner's the end of their
evening so I just kind of died I kind of
died black I kind of dive rolled and
like my knee like I thought he didn't go
like you would think of you fall I could
go over that way he went like this yeah
and then I rolled for like a mile and a
half yeah
my knee is [ __ ] up my hip is [ __ ] up
both of my balls are gone it's a lot of
dicey things are happening to me right
now we have a 6 6 4 is the fastest time
right yep now let's hear Artie's four
six six four six let's just call it six
for Shelly no there Ari's amazing time
okay now this point I go breathe make
sure to breathe take long strides you're
longer than these guys don't don't not
use that advantage so should be noted I
watched re one time try to swim from one
side of a pool to the other holding his
breath and he chose to swim on top of
the water as opposed to under the water
so the idea that you didn't breathe
during a run makes total [ __ ] sense
in your brain yes okay so so you shade
off how much time on your first time
about 0.3 seconds and I shaved off point
four seconds right I've about five
tenths of us okay all right so what's
your arteries amazing next 15.75 yeah a
full second oh there's no way a full
second autumn if you're going for that
you're clapping for zionism okay III
what happened let's
oh yeah that looks a lot faster Dory on
this charity a little wind do the wind
pick up Oh God so nobody looks at this
kids timer Ferraris run coming in strong
with a snap pop good job Aaron I will so
then we're like let's all race at the
same time he's acting like he was like
oh dude you barely show it yeah I was
bleeding from my entire left side for
the second race and I finished my ass
the whole time that is true I will give
you that defense that you're probably
anemic we all ran at the same time and
it was no question I was just like to
see you guys no no the original that was
let's run the 41 who wins it I did sorry
he does this all the time he gets all I
win
yeah that's right my Netflix special
double negative on Netflix right now
looks like a single negative now idiot
you should have called a JFK holy [ __ ]
right to the brain god that was like a
bomb went off thank you Sam stop eating
chocolate god I feel like I was just in
Hiroshima why did you come Burt what we
wanted to do with four guys in their
forties run in the 40 oh why didn't I
think so why did I come to this I was
like um today you're like I'm right here
what more do you want I'm sitting right
next to you I wanted to take a nap
before my show it's a good thing I did
because because we're all bleeding and
old dude I walked up into that pool
party right across thing I was walking
up the stairs and all those stairs I was
like oh my god
my legs are dead I ran a hundred and
twenty yards in 40 minutes and my body's
destroyed well sprinting is different
than jogging thank you I appreciate that
defense
that payments you [ __ ] that up right
there [ __ ] it up anyone knows the
Dodgers score Dodgers score
what is it Dodger score anybody know
Houston's winning yeah five one bottom
of the sixth two on one out who's up
probably up weak Jews
I feel like week bats 11 times a it's
like you like uh-oh he's not good right
now you'd be my team well we just got
into a hole for no reason at all
yep sure did sure Russia I wish I
against you guys yeah so do we that's
why we invited you can someone mark out
a hundred yards real quick hundred forty
a forty that's super easy
do you ever got you guys do stupid [ __ ]
oh you don't even know who suck to me
because I you don't even know the new
one dude what's the new one ah we have a
football team they all ever finish with
the same record wins everyone else does
a reverse Kobayashi do you know what
that means
hold on no no they don't okay uh hold on
yeah I know Kobayashi is the hot dog
eating Jam yeah yeah so you've got to
put them in your [ __ ] Wow frozen
dipped in Lube no loopers my choice it's
not a bad I mean I could definitely do
it
I've been practicing and I got 11 Dodger
dogs in my ass at one time the other day
I feel pretty confident at the bout your
[ __ ] like a t-shirt gun cannon is
that what that reverse t-shirt gun
cannon where you just keep below it's
like if you're just like on the side of
a pirate ship and you're loading things
in to shoot off later if they said a
million dollars a hotdog to go up your
ass but you had to hold it up there for
a month
no come on
I mean I'm Audi bow how many hot dogs
you think you could shove up your ass
how many you got how long do I get what
are we talking about
today plump when you cook them shove hot
dogs in my ass and chew bubblegum and
I'm all out of bubblegum how many hands
up you're so nervous dude don't worry
about a thing
[ __ ] I just how long do I gotta keep him
in my ass cry sure I was gonna just say
like thank you ten minutes oh okay all
right three let's see let's play a game
hold something up their ass for the
longest what is it every subpoena
buttercups I'm gonna take one of these
tripods okay bro gate no we're not doing
this now we're not doing this now we're
already doing it at the end of the
football season it's meant to be a
punishment you feel excited about this
yeah what do you think it was shoes on
do you think you could beat all of our
100% personal baguette bets no I don't
do that
because I can't get a tattoo of Mickey
Mouse on my no we can't say I wanted
percentage all the way back these are
all things that we said each one of us
said if I lose something that I'm sure
I'll win we are I'm willing to do it
tattoos I've already said no to [ __ ]
like that I'm like I'm never gonna do
that yes you what would it be
we have to pick it out randomly from the
bag of bet let's do this let's do it so
what the last one I just got I have to
beg for money like a homeless person
until you have $40 I think and then give
that to a homeless person and the last
one I go to my last one I just got I
have to dress like a [ __ ] walk around
Santa Monica Boulevard for one hour
after midnight okay okay I got a nipple
pierced but you can take it off no yeah
okay me I don't I'd watch two hours of
gay porn on [ __ ] uh Holly did that
earlier research room I did do a bong it
off of Ahri's [ __ ] we'll give you
three runs three three runs to be your
all your times the best time that we had
was what Johnny oh no I can't go with or
he's fake time ya know now that the
money is on it I can't go with our real
time let me roll the gate
guys loading footage and let me see
[ __ ] Blade Runner over here look at
my lips I guess those fake legs
right after I figure out stride I'm
bleeding from every part of my left body
by the way hold on stop right there stop
right there look at Tripoli's already I
don't know how to run Oh
Tripoli does have the weirdest run I
look at height of the tiger on the left
re some balls of guising leaf it's the
Sam Sam Sam look who got a good jump
before he said go tell you something I
know that already sheet right there cuz
I tried to cheat and he beat me okay
I was trying I got hold on one second I
got I was I got caught in a Hodor mom
with a girl and a black football player
and the I was hiding under the bed in
the black guy was hiding by the door now
we're college and we came out and the RA
goes and I saw them in the [ __ ] room
and and I was like you didn't I didn't I
wouldn't in any room and she goes I saw
you in the room and she was and we were
like no and she goes I saw you and the
black guy goes you didn't see me I was
behind the door I saw you like you dumb
[ __ ]
I went on to play professional football
Derrick Brooks is that true oh is that
true no Tampa Bay Bucs aah no no no Eric
Alexander keep going um let me see that
okay perfect timing no jobs when he's no
job looks fair to me I agree with that I
will give you that okay look how much
I'm beating them by
oh my tongues out like Jordan okay now
you believe that five five well you know
that is the whole second that like seven
seconds ladies and gentlemen a big round
of applause for juicing bolts everybody
thank you thank you thank you have to
chew in the world Usain Bolt god damn
I'm fat what some let's get some
world-record 40-yard dash times for aah
be cool juice and be cool okay okay Ari
did not run you did not you did not
running back it's 575 not not 505 I
still it doesn't matter he didn't run
close for a guy who's not an athlete
there's no way he ran twice and then
took a whole second day you see him Lane
ich Youssef in basketball
there's no way this guy know what you
know what I'd like to I'd like to start
this video over why I'm gonna time it on
my [ __ ] stopwatch but this wasn't in
time that doesn't matter
I just okay this is all remotely close
to promote I also slow down when I
realize I'd beaten them by a couple
months okay Jake you slow down races
don't ever [ __ ] talk about
he's gonna say on your market said how
are things gonna catch up with you and
begin on your mark get set
are you ready not what everybody else
I'll give you a time later well I see
the first problem with the road yeah
yeah I can't it's hard for me to just go
and that's when he brought by the way
that's already 1.9 thank you okay I can
hear that and I can also see him when he
starts I got it okay here we go here we
go
stop BAM okay I got to give it to him
it's six seconds and you stopped it late
by the way I already passed it thank you
verify where I'm at you're gonna go run
on the street on the ground the tape
measure someone just so we don't a tape
measure no I'm just gonna test myself
ten Johnny Johnny dude you can't do that
Johnny's oh honey it's gotta be my
second timer it's got an excellent timer
weird you bag of bats this bag of bats
what's that do we have any do we have
any tape measures ATC of course they
don't I don't hang everything up so
beautifully without a tape measure
my biggest is I'll just measure it by
that yeah what anymore what do you know
that how do you we're gonna trust a guy
that got a deal I was about distance the
dashes they they're ten yards apart ten
feet apart so if I run four dashes
that's a 40-yard dash oh that's a
40-foot - [ __ ] 3-3 12 of those
that's a lot of I'll accept while the
roads as a run go Johnny bats did anyone
bring the bag nobody brought the bag
no arrow-straight money let's go
straight money I can depart with money
easy yeah that's how we don't do that
okay
yeah what you know I'm saying no so what
we're gonna have them do oh I got a I
got a measure on my thing where I can
measure yardage what are you talking
about I'll just go
that seems trustworthy no no one lives
in golf yeah I can't believe how fat I
am well I will say this Ari was running
and I saw the slow-motion video of you
and you you were the only one that was
shirtless yeah and at one point in time
you had so much [ __ ] moving around your
right nipple went over your back and
then I came back to you 40-yard dash
that would be a hundred and twenty foot
yes under 20 foot [ __ ] off
hey stop that's a Florida State
Education everybody this is winning time
can you can do that fast one I can't
speed it up right now god I was gonna
have you time it but you know what time
ago motion I would like to raise that
one tape measure all right hundred
twenty feet Johnny we'll go with you
he'll time you you'll measure it out
you'll run it and then we'll come back
I'm gonna hear what you do you record
that and then no bet no back a bets
what's the bet you coming up Tuesday
you'll draw out one you'll do that one
no I don't know if you live you win we
all do it
no no I know I'm barefoot number one no
your shoes on I'm not gonna go to my
room and put on track clothes what size
shoe are you 15 okay I'm weird 15 so I'm
wearing size 15 heels you're in luck
tell you what tell you what come down on
Tuesday to punch-drunk oh you're in the
next Tuesday and run it it's Tuesday
we're doing which we'll call it what not
running it's earlier than that I gotta
let me what Paul and Kevin and bean
early in the morning okay this is 11:00
to 1:00
how many more excuse do you want
you got a goddamn tape measure in your
left hand what does that mean what about
if we give him a point for who thinks
Bert can beat my time what Oh Joel don't
you [ __ ] dare let it ride come on
Yuri run one more time what if we re all
right what if we give him like because
he's barefoot here it is in great shape
I would like to I would like to sprint
by the window you guys take a look at my
running okay and then judge from that
okay no president come in the window
there is absolutely no way John II think
that we are not going to approve and let
him run this he's gonna be trotting by
like a drunk horse he is gonna scrape
the [ __ ] out of his feet don't let him
hurt himself never for massage yeah that
guy's a size 15 already ran a five nine
oh there he goes he's hauling dog that
was that look like I got it just stole a
[ __ ] credit card that was like a dine
and dash speed ah dude bro bro you
should lay down the line I say re re re
and Sam I say we give him because he's
barefoot point three seconds oh [ __ ]
that just come in just come in next
Tuesday come in next Tuesday oh yeah we
could just race I don't waste barefoot
I'm gonna [ __ ] Savage
I'm [ __ ] really out of breath yeah
that's tight you know I'm you know I
haven't supported from something in a
really cool assed time I ran that much I
swear to god it was police dogs chasing
me at Indiana University
I like how we even said that not I
haven't spread that I haven't sprinted
from something
yeah and that's because that's cuz
that's all things coming hey dude my
feet are [ __ ] killing me I was a
really bad idea they have stone in
between the path yeah what's that dress
shoes I was in football if flops
I'm Florida kid florida state's finest
yep all right well listen as we talk
about athletics I think we should bring
one of the most athletic people in the
world thank you
George st. Pierre everybody George st.
Pierre is here George is here
unfortunately really really yeah by the
way saying that was an intervention for
you on that screen I'm dying O'Neal's
here though if you guys want to talk to
him okay right O'Neill everyone one of
my good friends a straight up region rat
re going on guys ah Bert would destroy
all of you guys I think oh I saw him
he's what could you run [ __ ] oh I
could be pick him up all of you guys
ever
he runs barefoot in the hill yeah really
yeah he runs some he takes on come out
then I'm out what do you think your 40
time would be though my 40 well I don't
know what are professional athletes
before 244 yeah I probably high fours
I'll go I'll probably low five what does
that mean five one five three two five
four well that's mid fives well five
three is the lower part of five three
well yeah 500 five one five two those
are the lows five three or we talked
about a minute low five threes low Oh
George st. Pierre low we find the phones
okay finally we had to go to another
state to fix the phones
I suggest you Vaseline your bodies too
now what would that do for us George if
we were to Vasily in our bodies it
doesn't seem like wind-resistant then
try our kitty litter and computer spray
before running well I would imagine that
with us how would that help us is it
like a moment when it kicks in where
it's like really Jack sue just gives you
a boost of adrenaline like you've never
felt in your life yeah I can imagine
what's the best way to Vaseline your
body by using Vaseline okay I didn't
know if you soak in it or yeah you're a
bath tub guy aren't you George
I prefer that bath tub but there are
many methods ah [ __ ] weird right it's
like lightning
I know god damn those cups look who's
wearing a Cubs hat right there
I'll tell you where it comes that you
get snap pops for our eggs yes I suggest
behind the ear and the side of the face
tell us about your fight coming up are
you excited like a pirate it's like the
movie The Fugitive but the UFC fight
okay what are you think about Michael
Bisping refusing to take you as a caller
on those podcasts it's all trash
I think England should be thrown out of
the United States okay I respect that
that makes sense
England should be thrown out of the
United States see Mike you you're not
wearing your headset oh I'm on my phone
oh hi George
oh great one for the record hit his head
phone and he goes ow thought I hit my
neck no it did not watch if I face some
mark is right there you have Tweaker
vision now we pulled out the breaker
vision Jesus
now we both have tweaked our vision
idiot is there an active shooter no
everything's okay everything's okay
George um now that ronda rousey's out of
fighting could I see a rekindling of
that romance or what's going on are
there any other female MMA fighters you
got a little excitement for good
question I have tried with Ronda I
showed up her at her wedding in Hawaii
but it did not go so well why what
happened what happened weight fighter
and we got into a scrap okay Lou who won
he's bigger than you how did that go
down I mean uh he's out of like a five
fight losing streak right so I mean you
got a shot he is but I was so
disheartened that I left
now we're throwing snap pops into the
audience and it's got none really now we
have a potential all things comedy
lawsuit yeah our first lawsuit hey
you're not a podcaster he gets to
quickly iPad tall make it an LLC real
quick you guys are legit now so what
about you I need you on Jed check it
take away from Tony hitch close yeah yes
okay is xeni one thing toning her the
same person I you know I noticed you
never see them at the same place at the
same time you constantly see them posing
together yeah maybe it's like a photo
show is the worst lawyer move ever right
yeah but the conspiracy theorists didn't
go like Photoshop you know you got any
questions for George uh yeah how are the
aliens like what's their game plan for
you for this fight with Bisbing oh yeah
and will they be in your corner George
that's a good question
the aliens I will not be in my corner
but they are always in my head
okay George a lot of people say that
you're really not to use a phrase from
this podcast but your punch-drunk and
you're an idiot and there are no aliens
and you're a [ __ ] [ __ ] who sees
things
whoa that's America that's what I say to
that ha ha
that was for you George I came out of
retirement Ari so I can get punch-drunk
I am not there yet and that the aliens
are telling me to uh to jab duh and to
do a lot of drugs before the fight now
are you gonna focus on his bad eye I am
going to do a lot of eye poking okay oh
that's Marty the good one is a bad one
she pointless to do it - the bad one I'm
going to use that both is the crow gonna
be there he will be there he's there's
an after-party for the crow at the
crow's nest in Vegas in Vegas but I'm
fighting it New York oh no George wait
how does he get to Vegas through the
spaceship I used to ride his bike
because funds are low right now in my
camp david awasum wow that's a long ride
i could even afford more than a bike um
George let me ask you real quick are
what are some of the things in their own
language that the aliens have been
saying to you to motivate you and what
does that mean in their language it
means take them down to the ground this
ground game is weak as you go from the
arm bar I love that people almost from
another dimension literally light-years
away are concerned about your grounded
pound
they are big gamblers George Harsha they
location so I get it where did you learn
the alien language on their planet
that's a dumb question next question
I'll give you that I heard you're
trading with Anderson Silva does he have
any advice for what you're gonna do and
how this fight is gonna go he said
[Music]
it's perfect for the Portuguese that was
pretty good Portuguese and we've now
learned that submission is submission in
Portuguese yeah look Gauri
Oh Lane gentleman Andrew Dice Clay on
the phone is that dice wait are you with
is the dice man with a P now I saw I I
understand one time you had to take the
bus one of the guys from the bus ride in
here earlier who is it was the candy guy
young black youth young black youth I
heard what he said about the Jews he's
gonna meet the ham ari Hait anybody in
the audience have any questions for dice
or Jorge any questions no okay they
don't really give a [ __ ] about either
one of you I guess you're both
irrelevant Georgia you're no longer a
UFC fighter and haven't been for a long
time and injure Dice Clay you're still
doing the Riviera in Las Vegas Nevada
doing the same Matt you were in 2004 we
were driving out here and he's playing
so now Brittany rinky-dinky casino was
where was he my face on a billboard I've
seen your face on a milk carton are you
saying I'm missing from my family which
would be a great thing sorry I think
this is because you were banned from his
house that sounds like a little bit of
jealousy yeah that sound like jealousy
yeah who plays my wife on my show
my ex-girlfriend etosha yeah dice are
those sex scenes with her real is there
full penetration
Shia LaBeouf in it okay how do you feel
about that Ari you know dice I just want
to know your finger if that's possible
we got it for old times sake yeah yeah
we got a question with the audience oh
we did one of them yeah he wants to know
where you keep the hammer yeah where do
you keep the hammer you ever seen a
carpenter on the belt oh oh
so it's always on you almost like your
gloves like your fingerless gloves it's
right there they don't blister when I'm
hitting Ari with the hammer it's like
he's Batman he's that man Tildy belt I
don't say that his answer was gonna be
why don't you ask Ari cuz he'll be right
back to my drawers he'll find them now
you're rewriting is [ __ ] jokes
well he needs it I just want to snap
hops in Madison Square no I've been
there exactly zero no dice I understand
re at one point in time was rifling
through your affairs is that true or are
we to my house
I think I know I see the guy rifling
through my I've never rifles through
your affairs dice you said you had a gun
in your drawer I said you're lying and
you said let's bet $100 you know I
didn't have hundred dollars back then I
was in your office it was a walk through
to your living room
Freddie Soto lied this is why he's dead
and he said and he said burn in hell
Freddie Soto and this isn't he said I
was rifling through your affairs I was
not and you know I wasn't and you just
banned me for no reason there was no
evidence everyone call you the rifleman
who called me the rifleman I got less of
a [ __ ] judicial process in Ezekiel
Elliott they call you the Welsh that's
what they call you oh well sure for sure
that is true remember when you're
supposed to fight me in Vegas yeah I do
remember that remember I did you duck
him and why did you duck salmon why
won't you fight either of these two I
said I'd fight Sam no Ellis mania and
Sam said he couldn't get over shitty gig
a few weeks before yeah that's when
Ellis offered it I said sure I'll take
it I'm ready he's afraid the whole time
how convenient Orry yes how convenient
that fight would have been Sam said no
I've got a gig and jason Ellis you know
his infinite wisdom and generosity said
I will pay the money that you will miss
for your gig and I will fly you to Vegas
problem solved new problem cowardly
whenever you want would you fight the
dice man arm would you fight him in one
hour what I've had two dice man yeah you
want to fight one an hour we're gonna
fight right now I wear the gloves at all
times are we worried that they're
putting you up in the board members
sweep they seize board members suite oh
right in the room in the room you
probably have a huge my music in the
room oh you didn't beat em I had him in
a rear naked choke he resorted to biting
my [ __ ] you were wearing corduroys
that were burning my face white cross
the gun don't get Dokic on the drug on
you and you've eliminated my interest
rule who bid who
I felt burning I was doing gonna get
choked in I was like I'm doing what
Eddie taught me and I'm like why is it
burning in my elbow and then I look up
and [ __ ] vampire face over here I've
got a [ __ ] piece of my arm and he
just goes there show you that any
Bravo's jujitsu doesn't work on the
street he doesn't ee doesn't worry about
everything but here's the thing
O'Neill's a black belt in Taekwondo it's
not like a bunch of [ __ ] fat [ __ ]
like that I know exactly train do you
have a weapon on you right now yes what
is it
[Laughter]
hey hey he's not a redneck he's a region
rat you know Niels the fence Sam train
with Kevin James diet coach as well
Oh guys wearing a white shirt makes me
fat just called is this Black Hawk Katie
Katie everybody black car and we get a
screener for this [ __ ] podcast
instead of just having people just get
on the line it's just it's it's October
27th hey wait wait Katie Katie Katie I
just wanna I just want to make this
clear people are knocking on your door
little children and you're giving them
Irish car bombs for Halloween it does
not sound safe Katie now how much of you
drinking today it's actually not
Halloween yet so what size
jack-o'-lanterns are we talking okay
Costco just Costco sell jack-o'-lanterns
I didn't know they did I'm in Phoenix
Phoenix Arizona
yeah yeah I'm sorry if this offends you
I really am Katie but yeah I'm sober for
October okay t remember how to assemble
that okay - remember what everybody uh
what you were [ __ ] in the bathroom in
the hallway the Commerce door people
walk in on you and after the fourth
person walked in and you said get the
[ __ ] out of here and never and never
even decide to lock the door are you at
a bar right now early it's also what
what are people dressed up as good
question one guy has throw-up on his
face and you think he's dressed it's a
zombie what's in a car bomb it's a yeah
that's it that's not sure right I look
it up Johnny look it up but I believe
it's like Guinness and then a shot of
whiskey dropped into the Guinness well
you just listed 11 drinks that we're in
an Irish Car Bomb but I think you're
doing your own sort of thing here hey
Katie since you've been banned from the
comics where are you finding all your
black dick now they're playing so poorly
okay Katie led the campaign to get them
to move to Los head oh it might be why
the Rams are playing so good yeah that's
true
five and two Wow pressed Katie how do
you feel about the Red Sox firing their
manager oh really the higher Jo poore
can't believe a funny something out from
Katie
he's joking re in choked it answer the
[ __ ] they'll see us
what that is not why that is not my
point
I was sober the entire time when they
beat the twins when they beat the
Cleveland Indians no well it took
Houston Astros to seven the Houston
Astros about soon to be world champions
keep stepping on the ones that miss and
it bothers me now Dan you know I miss
calling in Jameis Winston's father
I do miss playing now I don't know I
wish okay but I will say this and let us
know if we have another caller how is
drunk tober going for you and Jeff oh I
mean great Jeff yeah probably in the
bathroom throwing up right now because
you're so wasted
yeah I've been participating really
[ __ ] high it feels great are you
really took the whole my big drunk the
whole month and on drugs
I would never drop on all kinds of drugs
are drugs amber I was waiting for drug
member oh yeah we celebrate that day
yeah yeah we're not like these [ __ ]
no no no I didn't want to do it I did it
today last one we've been doing cold
yoga by the way what does happen you got
like a cryogenic chamber yeah a freezer
have you enjoyed being so bad would you
continue it are you gonna go right back
to drink it yeah okay no right back to
drinking he says he's pretty positive
about that all right I respect that
right back to drinking like hard
drinking hard going drinking the win
[ __ ] blood bro let's get let's be
blood brothers are your pay phones
ringing are you are he's gonna hook up
with a chick who was so hot last night
you didn't even know she's wearing
diapers that's how hot she was white
jeans diapers that's cuz you've had some
effect your ass yeah I think those are
more adult diapers than they are just
how many championship-level boxes of you
[ __ ] Katie Mike Tyson
what if we don't count him thank you can
I knew that was gonna go a direction
that none of us thought so
oh yeah this is that's your last one all
right keep stuff ladies and gentlemen
the magic one of the biggest sports man
oh yeah oh so you just get drunk and
punch people drunk sports it's so
feminine the way you guys touch each
other it's pure love there was a moment
there where I thought I was like I think
about to kiss piano would have been nice
yeah that was a Doug Stanhope guy stop
it
bigger comics that there are you don't
stand hope is Cecil's number-one comic
so guys shut up you've never heard of
Doug Stanhope Tice okay it's pretty
weird it's pretty right watch that
though anybody else I'd pay five bucks
to watch a Johnny Depp Andrew Dice Clay
[ __ ] fest yeah yeah absolutely
who's top who's top in that it wouldn't
matter they get my five bucks out of the
way yeah I think dice is on top with
that I don't see dice taking a different
role than on top I see your Johnny Depp
I raised you a Bradley Cooper oh [ __ ] I
could see you [ __ ] Bradley Cooper to
Dice Clay I'd want to know I'm not gonna
lie about that would that be available
for a season a free seaso trial that
should be on our [ __ ] that should be
on our patreon we could have that on
that so is it there's nothing we have to
do to pay off this with your victory it
was just straight up to for bragging
rights right yeah we didn't beg
that's us I mean Sam would never go for
it he knew he's gonna lose but you so
you can go to our patreon and eventually
you can watch all three of us oh yeah if
you go to patreon you can find it all ha
I need to get in shape I mean it does it
take this for us to know we need to get
in shape
yeah all three of us are half of 90 the
tea the t-shirt that a fan made on his
own not for no request of mine that Sam
Tripoli spat that didn't help in any way
no because that's just I mean were you
ever a capable runner no okay I was
voted most improving my high school
bowling team I've always been honest
yeah is that a [ __ ] category yeah I
really did so that was that means one
year you were a liability to your high
school bowling team which you got almost
try to be no dude I went from a 185
bowling average to a 230 bowling average
I'm when you're sure you could beat me
in bowling I mean you didn't
oh no when you [ __ ] I fell for your
mind tricks ha ha ha well he played
those same mind tricks today which was
hey let's all do a 40-yard dash and see
who wins Yeah right I want to I want 9
more time tonight so listen Leo I
recognize Jason Tebow Sam is the best
bowler on this show thank you Oh God and
he keeps stepping all the ones that
don't blow up so sorry how's your belt
going how's your new belt I do have a
new belt oh yeah let's see your belt
I just got it it's bought it that's it
right there
it's from matrix there's a skateboard
company I'm really happy about it
uncomfortable I just I could hear every
girl here just throw up in her mouth
it's a it's really those are disgusting
yeah
that seat will never be that was trust
bro I fell I fell I found I'm running a
fast forty you're acting very rude for
someone who wanted to see my fashion
sense yeah because you try to stuff it
down my gullet quick selfie without you
forcing it in my mouth wait does that
does that violate our truce let me just
see you love it
my head was never touched let me see
your new belt all I want to do see
that's friendly that's friendly oh no
you guys are taking it too far
dad trying to keep this [ __ ] positive
they're gonna have to clean that seaweed
gasoline and now now let's check in with
Erin Erin how are we doing on YouTube
right now by the way we got that in 3d
nice 3d for dick is there gonna make his
dick look bigger and smaller because I
would like to show you my new belt if it
makes it look bigger
Hey look at these people on the street
they just walk by it's a family I think
[Applause]
they god they're coming to the show oh
look at it jiggles like a bag of change
the guys pretending not to see you
there's a little kid but you don't pull
up your pants you just walk back oh and
now you know I couldn't only see half of
our show on YouTube every Tuesday from
11:00 no no no no no no Ari Ari
seriously all right show them you
[ __ ]
show them your [ __ ] turn around I
want them to see the Vice gotcha hi look
guys look into it look into it don't
look away
it's got vice grips this looks like a
horror movie when they film the audience
how they all went back oh somebody
simply take a whiff
[Laughter]
hey wait if you guys never done if you
guys done a bag of Vesper you have to
take a shot from our E's [ __ ] Oh God
don't even say that again don't even get
that nice oh look at our East 1920s
[ __ ] George piece look that's no
problem
look at this guy look how bad that looks
[Laughter]
relax okay look how bad that looks for
both of us it literally looks like I'm
blowing him if no one can cop on me you
can come up and see the photo that looks
like I'm like I like I really looks like
I'm blowing him I'm not gonna set you up
a [ __ ] where you knew okay good idea
good question from Douglas Stanhope oh
my god the worst ninja I've ever seen in
my life naked ninja my pants are up this
all came down to my Bell focus and my
thighs like oh this is getting good
oh hey can I propose a bag of bets yeah
somebody know we do a shot no worries
that down Ari's ass cracks underneath it
and do the shot I don't know there's a
lot of it's a legitimate question why
would you jerk off the gay porn on Molly
Dennis where you been the [ __ ] we
missed the whole podcast
he's so wasted he could barely make it
for drunk tober I was so wasted I was in
the bathroom puking but I'm back yeah
what'd I miss
uh not a lot fun podcast pretty much ari
showed his belt and then you came right
back we took a lot of calls from several
do you get a new belt Ari
yeah I dig about sperm matrix we're
really very trusting friends but when
we're doing his podcast Sam turned my
collar down I'm like what the [ __ ] he
doing man he's like security or
something I think I think it was like it
I think they reported them everything
okay there's the guy with the huge balls
he's not a girl scouts walk by and you
got your [ __ ]
I imagine security would show I will
tell you when the mom walked by saw me I
thought it was funny and then when I
looked and saw she was holding like a
three-year-old girl was a little person
that she's dating ari if they report you
that's anti I told you looks like Ari's
Nikki all gone better news is that a
ghost [ __ ] that's a new school photo
option it's like a little bit coming out
my other ear yeah what backdrop do you
want it's like Steve Martin's hero like
Steve Martin's there looks like he has
PTSD right now look at that Aaron looks
like on every episode why don't you just
say I'm thinking like I went to school
for this audio engineering
you guys should sell that on patreon as
a screen saver matrix if you want to
sponsor that screen saver is that the
new jou dick phone yeah that's the
iPhone 10 inches nah he wishes but oh my
god I mean I feel pretty positive about
what we've done so far re you have paid
off your bag of bets for all the pops
we're out of pocket so thank you thank
you you took them all to the head you
took about 80 poppets to the head to the
back - that's worth way more than I
thought it would I thought it would hurt
zero and just be like a fun thing uh-huh
the ring in the ear I got the one you
got behind the ear but that's not from
us that's on the other side that's from
some other [ __ ] you look like you went
to Fight Club
alright will you be doing the stand-up
live show or will you be getting laid
from the 14 year old you were talking to
last night after the show hopefully the
latter I might use as their excuse to be
like hey I gotta go to the stand-up show
but there's a chance I don't show up
that's also a nice photo of us re that's
gonna be our Christmas card that William
H Macy
cooller right there that looks like I
like that like for like a horror movie
about like this Dixit god loose you guys
that you can convince people this is
shot on Jupiter because the gravity is
taking it down so hard are you go out
your pubes or pube ember is that what it
is you definitely have a 1970s dick and
balls situation going on like we sent
the girl you're about to bang tonight
these pictures with that help or hurt
your said she wouldn't care she was I
think it'd be weird if she suddenly got
a bunch of pictures of my dick from
someone else
yeah was she was she really young young
she's gonna be 22 and 9 years was that
the girl was that the girl with the mom
that was just walking by how'd you meet
her Netflix she came out last night she
was at the show last night
what'd she say go to school in the
morning yeah talk I have a book report
to you can you give a binder I can put
this in do you have a binder hey you
look like the kind of guy that has a
trapper keeper so are you gonna see her
tonight yeah guys why isn't she here
yeah cuz I'm doing this right now hey
you're doing the live podcast is way
harder than than doing the normal
podcast because when it dies it dies
hard yeah it does die hard people like
mark no mark no well I mean it's like
it's it's like a hard to peak after you
walk around naked and pound I should say
that closer yeah for sure to say that
looking back you guys got greedy
I mean Ari got greedy by the way I got
tickets from some you know industry
about about for the Jets Panthers game
and I get to root against the Panthers
full-on so no I'm not November 29th
November 29 are you told you have a good
memory
there's no reason look it up cuz already
know the answer oh there's no reason I'm
this is yep yep that's what I said what
do you guys hate you guys are doing
Darryl Neil doing the podcast yes what
do you guys have coming up
you mean minutes yeah stick around if
you want to see the Danish and O'Neill
podcast live by the way Danish what's up
when I my dick was it well I was showing
off my belt my penis fell out by
accident
oh yeah no no no no hit me in the dick
with a bottle of water
you broke the truce on Tuesday night
bottle of water what's the truth on the
head Dennis no no no that's a ladle no
layer of the Bell he do not violate the
truth explain the terms of the the we
had a three-way ball war see yeah it got
bad it got crazy to the point where I
was I took was taking a nap one day and
I woke up in the middle of it and just
grabbed my balls and screamed because I
thought somebody was attacked would hide
behind the stage of the commerce store
wait till he was on where he felt safe
no is he me I loves you and uh and then
what he wasn't look I just came behind
him and just [ __ ] pop him the nuts it
was non-stop it was not stuff and it got
to the point where we said we need to
stop and if anyone violates this
treaties make a truce you know those dog
things that you throw the tennis ball
with if you're lazy to really throw it
yeah yeah yeah on in the comedy store
kitchen and you bend it back as far as
it goes the other person holds the other
person's arms back and you take a
full-on ladle to the nuts it already
violated that treaty and he got a ladle
to those big flow here's the thing you
had to hit him with your hand what that
was the rule you had to hit him with
your are you talking about technicality
was a Butterfinger it was a bottle of
water that's a burn I owe you a
Butterfinger Andy he really did he I
think Chrysler like ran barefoot and was
treating trick-or-treaters in the room
[Laughter]
time to get tough please gentlemen Doug
Stanhope I am NOT a guest on the podcast
or no detention but I know as soon as
Ari Shaffir wipes his dick against the
window at just general passers-by and
children yep I can smoke and I feel like
I feel like if Doug Stanhope can smoke
after Ari wiped his balls on the thing I
can do cocaine off this table how are we
with me on that into a pillow because of
your podcast so sit on his lap I'll sit
on this lap we don't like it we'll
switch up partners later of course this
has been the most homo comedic show
we've ever done in our life I don't know
if that's all the truth awesome not
really never were none of us ever were
we have to grow we have to girls with
boyfriends and a table of girls that are
gonna sprint the [ __ ] out of here the
minute this ends at a five point six
point one clip that none of the three of
us could catch them by the way Bert
would you de Winne I saw you running out
there who said that I came in I do have
a switchblade in my pocket so he's not
happy to have you guys come for the dick
if you guys come for the dick you guys
want some dick because I'm out I'm out
you should seem show me your bathroom
Johnny Johnny come on pull up the
pictures real quick show him your belt
they want to see your bail these young
white Republicans wanna see your belt
and there's a woman in the window long
as a child please be cool be cool be
cool
ari is that is that by yourself
save yourself others in yourself to all
the therapy haha
get her out the only way this ends bad
is you with another kid yeah but that
might be the mother that had the child
that walked by earlier she might have
brought the dad back to beat the [ __ ]
out of Aria can we get a Dodger score
from anybody three five one inning
eighth inning three five I was at my
friend's house she's a lesbian single
mother and there's a baker's I went to
the bathroom she goes she has a
five-year-old she goes can she watch her
pee cuz she needs to see what a penis
looks like before it's what she doesn't
want the first penis feces to be the one
going into her mouth dude why would she
choose yours yeah but this one she said
she was like why does it come out of
that thing you gotta start with the
story where have you been with did you
let her shake it off no but then she
went to touch me I was like crossing a
line children up here you walked into
someone's house they said my knowledge
needs to see you pee yeah you said cool
I said yeah okay
okay the kids five something like that
okay and then you walked into the
bathroom with a five-year-old alone you
pulled your dick out the five-year-old
child said you're like oh watch what is
this thing you're not going to happen
how come you do it like that
some along those lines and then she said
why is this so puny for her actual words
and I was like wow I mean I wouldn't
bend over [ __ ] I'll show you a beauty
yeah this I could hear this story again
I don't know if she knows with her
purely means she knows what the word
puny me and she goes what's all that
stuff she try to touch it does like no
no no no those are barnacles did you did
you slap her you slap her hand away or
did you just I just kind of barely push
it away not for three more years uh who
can piss under that kind of pressure it
was it was definitely difficult no [ __ ]
I can't piss judging your [ __ ] so next
ball she sees are gonna be like
surprisingly taut competitive are there
any visible warts that she could have
seen no not this time
all right I'm gonna play a game I'd like
everyone up on the mic we're gonna go
around Robin I'm gonna be a parent I'm
gonna ask my kid can what you'd be
alright
that's real quick Doug Georgia I'd like
Georgia to watch you take a piss real
quick is that cool with you she's old
though like a friendly childlike way
yeah girls when I was that age yeah yeah
like on their leg people like a training
okay I think this games going wrong you
started with standoff am I in his
defense you were started I can't believe
this is real Stanhope has a childlike
innocence so of course you would be less
creepy if he peed on the child then let
her just watch you pee grab at it well
you're just making eye contact with the
hotel where you guys look at each other
look at what's going on how did you end
it you guys hug her I topped it off
what's their pillow talk a more you know
it's gotta be top the story yeah did you
guys schedule like another P date no
anyone else is blown away by this story
why does she need me your kids seen your
dick no I was raised by lesbian soccer
Georgia she described it since I was 10
I was raised by lesbians I never piss on
Orissa beer coke Stanhope got pissed on
our insecure dog Stanhope just pissed on
our a severe ladies and gentlemen that
has been punching guys very much
I don't know how we can top that I love
all you guys very much man thank you
guys for listening
hey thank you for supporting all things
comedy